back to life that's the new campaign  launched today to help spread covid  vaccine awareness and support the local  black community  it's an effort from the county health  district and local leaders they tell us  through outreach events and social media  they hope to counter any hesitancy  and eliminate any barriers to vaccine  access  the name of our campaign says it all  let's get back to life  whether it's work spending time with our  family enjoying local restaurants  and retail stores we want to return to  our normal course of action in our  in our everyday lives you can find all  the details on the new campaign on our  website  eight newsnow dot com